alright so in this video we're going to
talk about the resources tab of the
chrome dev tools the resources tab
allows you to view some of the
externally loaded things like SQL
databases cookies session storage things
like that so I have opened up my
Pinterest page and I'm looking at local
storage we've got active conversations
appears to be the key and a value the
values an empty array so I don't have
any active conversations right now
selected notification tab test so this
is some the information that they're
loading externally let's see if I have
any cookies from here oh I do look at
all these now most of our from Facebook
or Pinterest that seems to be where they
are all from which makes sense they're
linked for me
you can sort them by the domain by the
path by when they expire if they are
HTTP if they're secure which not all of
them are that's just part of the deal
with cookies here's the peers through
the Facebook ones so this is a really
useful tab if you're just looking to see
what resources externally a page is
using to run